more important things than a victory
today so
what's it like to know who you're
playing in the playoffs how to get
prepared
and how do you feel this team stands now
getting ready knowing
it'll be best of seven against the
pacers
um we're gonna go about everything the
same way that we always do
get better come tomorrow um make sure
our bodies are right
but we still got them one more time
before this whole playoff thing
started so you know we got to start by
sending the message then
and then what did you sort of think
today when the starters were in there at
the beginning
how the five you guys played play well
um we're still expecting to win that
game
but you know stuff happens we didn't we
didn't make shots they did
we didn't play heat basketball down the
stretch they took advantage of that but
um
i think we're our minds and our hearts
are still in the right place so
you know like i said tomorrow when we
get back on the port we get to get
better we get to learn from our mistakes
we're gonna hit this thing running
andre lopez go ahead thank you jimmy
uh there was an inbound play where
chris paul and duncan robinson kind of
got into a bit of a scuffle
and then it ended up with uh chris
chucking the ball at duncan
the very next play uh you took a charge
on chris
was that you kind of having your
teammates back and letting chris know
like
we're not gonna let this slide yeah i'm
i'm not gonna throw the ball with my
teammate like that
um so yeah i'll get a turnover get
offensive foul but
um we don't we don't do that here so you
you mess with one of my guys
especially one of my shooters then you
got to deal with me and everybody else
next question david lopez tv
uh jimmy big game for tyler tonight
obviously what's it like for you
watching to play with that type of
confidence out there
um that's who he is love that kid to
death
he's growing each and every time he
steps on a basketball court
obviously he can score the ball but he's
getting everybody involved
he's he's listening he's learning and
he's being coached
by everybody and he's just being a great
teammate
it's crazy that he's as young as he is
but he plays it he plays the game like
he's been in the league for a long time
okay last question cooper moorhead jimmy
tyler referenced how much
a lot of the vets and then coaches like
quinny have helped him as far as his
skills finishing in the paint
where have you seen him improve in that
area over the last year
with tyler yeah uh just
i mean his finishing knowing when to
make late decisions knowing when to
shoot the pull up floater
knowing when to hit the baseline or
pocket pass
um it's not surprising to me though
because he's always studying the film
he's always watching it before the game
after the game and the kid just wants to
be great
he wants to help bring a championship to
miami and i think
we're going to do that
thank you jimmy